joining me back here on the rich eisen
show he was kind enough to join me in
person in studio but right now we're
just zooming we're just uh
two guys on a zoom um
this guy can be seen right now on disney
plus in the beautiful wonderful film
called the one and only ivan based on a
wonderful children's book there's just a
lot of wonderful when it comes to danny
devito how are you danny
i'm really good how are you i'm better
for watching your movie my kids and i
watched it uh uh over the weekend and it
was just delightful just oh thanks yeah
i'm really proud of it it's a
it's a wonderful film uh the story's
really heartwarming and great and
touching and
uh the katherine applegate book
uh was you know the inspiration
for it and uh i've been working on it
for
long you know animated stuff takes very
long to do and
so i've been with it for a long time and
thea sharik who's the director
did a great job and disney's always very
supportive and they
they know they know the stuff you know
they know how to do it and so
um i had a good time really good time so
uh so how long
like one was this is like a year two in
the making something a couple of years
because uh
i i was actually doing the dumbo
in uh london when that's right i work
with thea
in a play uh the sunshine boys
years ago few about seven or eight years
ago
and uh you know i found out they were
doing this
and then it was a couple of years now
and it's very
complex because there's three parts to
the movie basically is the
the brian cranston playing the guy who
has the
roadside attraction and then there's a
motion capture
gorilla that is like amazing uh that
plays ivan
but sam rockwell does the voice so that
they had to do all that separate and
then there's the animation part which is
where i play
his best friend bob the dog and so
that's
i was very interested in the in the
process of the three
the hybrid kind of shooting so i did uh
i visited a lot and i also and it took
but basically mike white wrote the
script and
all the time you know just improvising
and trying new things and
trying to fit it all together with the
what the director wanted and
so it's but it's been an incredible fun
journey well
you know i've got um three kids they're
12
nine and almost seven so and and the
older ones have gotten to the age danny
where
if i make a suggestion they must now
reject it out of hand right like so
so i have to kind of like you know kind
of sell them a little bit
i'm like we're going to watch the one
and only ivan and they said who's in it
and look
i i i definitely did this i'd like the
cranky
[Music]
grandpa from jumanji the latest jumanji
i like honestly you know i could have
gone many other parts of your
filmography or television history but
the minute they heard that
they were like in and they recognized
your voice and
you know they they loved it so yeah it's
good you know
really good i've done like several uh
movies i did
i i actually i got my subscription to
disney plus and i uh
yeah to and uh and i
also just started surfing like a kid
again you know what
i actually went back and looked at
hercules which is another disney movie i
did
years ago where i played well he was not
his his his trainer you know and it was
i i got hooked on it again so it's like
really cool that
uh but the great thing is uh
you know we tried to make ivan for the
big screen uh
it was made for the big screen and then
all of a sudden we got one
you know whammied with the pandemic and
all this but i i really feel
it plays very well and really great the
the
uh and i think that uh a lot more people
see and they
have seen it this one weekend than than
probably would have
in the you know in the first weekend of
the
regular release but there's two there's
two aspects of disney plus that we
as a family during the quarantine uh had
to watch the first night out
it was your film the one and only ivan
danny in hamilton when hamilton came on
it was like we're sitting down
and we don't you know we're we're gonna
be one of millions of people watching it
so you're in select company
you can always you can always uh turn on
something out
put a big smile on your face on disney
well uh
during this uh danny devito here on the
rich eisen show again you can
you can uh watch uh the one and only
ivan right now on disney plus and then
when uh theaters near you begin to open
again maybe you can catch it there
um so what during the pandemic did
have you just flipped on and then oh my
god it's something that you were in you
hadn't seen in a while that you caught
up and just didn't
expect to see on your screen if you were
flipping around at any point in time
well i
i you know i kind of i do flip around
but mostly i
i dictate to myself what i'm gonna
you know where i'm going with my
watching you know my binging
and i've watched the sopranos three
times over the years
i've watched the wire now a couple this
is my second
go-round with the wire i like the you
know i love all those uh
those kinds of uh you know you know i've
been watching a lot of stuff
on on on hulu because of
uh fx all their oh sure
so um but once in a while you know you
catch a taxi and you go oh my goodness
you know you
you let's look at this for a little bit
and see what you were doing that
like uh how many years ago 1978
don't even you know like that's like you
know so
so long ago but it's it's kind of cool
i i think that's the one thing about you
know i've caught up a lot on
some movies like i i watch the criterion
collection and huh when i do a lot of
like um
hunting around once in a while i'll bump
into twins
because it's a time you know i love it
yeah i love it so
what let me let me hit on a couple of
those with you if you don't mind
um taxi when you first received the
script
you thought what you first well it was a
great great part and you know originally
i don't
people don't know it was written
originally for a voice only was it
wasn't going to be
louie wasn't going to be on camera and
then they decided
that you know they'd do it and when i
you know i came into their lives
i loved it so much when i read it i just
thought
you know this is a part that uh that i
have to play
i i you know i was i was not a kind of a
snob about television
even though it in the 70s a lot of
people were saying you know don't do
television it's like you know
i just thought you know i i it's a part
you know i'm an actor and
it was a great part and so i i went and
it was a luckiest thing
really it was a it was that's the the
thing that happens in your career
if it happens because you every actor's
out there struggling looking for work
uh and and you could do a lot of work
and
not have that one part click for you
and that happens to to it's like a
kismet kind of
like this perfect um spot to be in when
lightning strikes
and that was taxi that really was the
best
uh brought me out from you know into the
people's homes every
sure you know what a great character i
mean that you could absolutely
chew up and spit out and have a good
time rhythm
jim brooks and ed weinberger stan
daniels dave
all that team dave davis those guys were
uh from mtm mary tyler moore last year
remember that shows over there and
and they were just top-notch writers
should never let you down
and originally so again i guess to use
an m a mary tyler moore
production phrase i guess carlton your
doorman one of the more famous voices in
the history of
that was essentially what your character
was going to be
in the very beginning and then they
switched up
and said this guy in this really
crazy pit bull kind of you know in a
cage you know right
oh there i was it was like one of those
moments that
you know in you you you know come along
or you know once
if you're lucky once in a lifetime that
was a great time
were you channeling anyone in particular
i was doing everybody man i was like you
know
trying to be i don't know gleason
uh peter falk uh
everybody anybody i could think of who
was was good call of color in their
in their bones you know and uh
um uh you know i did meet a couple
people in new york who
i met the one guy who was it was based
like there was a there was an article
that was in
one of the magazines that's where they
found this
story about all the cab drivers who did
something else
one guy who was a cab driver that was
the judd character
everybody else like tony wanted to be a
boxer mary lou
was into art uh bobby wheeler wanted to
be an actor
you know right down the line and um
and uh but i didn't get to meet this one
guy in a in a
who was a dispatcher who was really a
pistol
this guy on 57th street in manhattan and
uh
so i got to hang out in the garage a
little bit with them you know
so a lot of things you know the way
actors collect things and
they rub off on you and you wonder so i
want to i want to
you know just while i'm going down
memory lane with you here danny
i mean uh one flew over the cuckoo's
nest if you have you caught that
any time lately every once in a while
i'll snag
onto that and i'll look at it you know
watch it and see
uh that was uh we shot that i think in
1974
and uh i'd done just some off-broadway
work and
a couple of little small parts and and
things but
uh that was a great that was also a
great gift
uh being able to do martini and
everyone's want to look at it and just
say where what what where did that guy
go you know
in there somewhere martini's still in
there somewhere but you know
it's like yeah caked in the in the crust
of
danny what was nicholson like on that
set
great great it was really it was a
pleasure to work with him you know we're
from the same neighborhood in new jersey
like nearby like say like i'm from
asbury he's from neptune
it's very close to down the shore
it's very close-knit thing i used to
always hear about this guy
this my sisters were older than
i was and they were they had a a friend
who
who's the baby brother or whatever went
to
california he was a really good looking
guy he went it was jack
it was jack and i used to hear about him
all the time being
a guy who's in california going to be he
hadn't been a
movie star yet and then all of a sudden
boom he bursts out on the screen and
he's like
you know there he is and then i saw a
lot of his films and then was cast in
cuckoo's nest and
i remember the first day in uh we were
in salem oregon
at a real um uh institution you know
it's like
and we were working on milo shot
everybody in the day room
and we had had 10 days rehearsal before
we started shooting
and during that time i never told him
and one day i guess michael told him
that i was from asbury and he came
around the corner
like with a big big smile on his face he
was like daddy why did you tell me for
master
and that was it we started talking about
all the people that we knew in common
like all the crazies from the jersey
shore all the wonderful people
that we grew up with you know and and uh
it was like really a cool thing because
we got to know each other
he only knew me as i and i was always in
character
martini was like really a pain in the
neck i was always like
you know insinuating myself to something
getting in on some
moving in this other people's space and
that
that way it was it was kind of fun
it's funny i mean of all the obviously
jersey people you hear about
all all the time obviously in in our in
our entertainment world and yes
a lot of journey you don't normally hear
nicholson as a
jersey guy i don't know maybe that's
courtside all those years maybe
yeah he's really very very jersey and i
didn't know him back then in the in the
in in town but but uh rumor has it that
he was always into basketball and always
into like
sports and always like a you know and
um and and so
but you know since of course since
we met in in in the 70s
we any time we get a chance we talk
about jersey that's the thing
we talk about down the shore then that's
like that was the
the golden place to be i mean if you
were in the east coast
the jersey shore was like asbury and
belmar and neptune minus
manasquan and all those places down here
long branch
that was like uh that was the creme de
la creme you know
so now obviously it makes sense you're a
bruce guy right
oh yeah i'm a lovely a big fan i've seen
tons of his concerts i'm a big fan of
his music and
uh and uh i went to see his play a
couple times i mean on broadway
it's actually him playing was actually
wonderful
great great all my kids are all
you know they all they're all uh
indoctrinated from
early on i i'd already left asbury
by the time he started settling in at
the stone pony
so i was in new york pushing the
sisyphus
acting rock and uh and uh he
he was uh you know forming the e street
band with
with little stevie and all the guys
and um but i assume
you know as soon as i saw that
burst onto the scene you know that was
like
it it's a weird thing because there
it's like any hometown thing i guess
with anybody but down there
the network of lights that go off when
my family found out i was working with
him in the
you know it was just like things lit up
when
when um you know i'm sure when when uh
you know bruce started hitting home runs
that uh
he was always hit i never saw him in the
stone pony but i've always heard
and i've seen like documentaries and
whatever and uh
so big big thing well i guess mentioning
little stevie brings this full circle to
you
binging oh my god i i just like you know
just like
totally still watching you know uh
a little stevie on uh he's great
yeah i've also seen him in the in this
uh
uh what the hell's the name of that uh
show he did uh
about where they did the olympics it was
in uh
how a hammer what where'd they do the
only hammer something
yeah he's done a show that is very funny
where he takes the character
that he okay basically does on sopranos
and goes in
a witness protection program you should
check it out i'll definitely
get a kick out of it i definitely will i
definitely will i get a kick out of our
conversations danny and oh
you know i could go on and on and on and
on with you so um
you know and you know you've been on
twice we've hardly even touched on uh
most of your career i would love to to
do this again in the meantime
i mentioned a beautiful movie my kids
absolutely adored it we've been talking
about it every day since then and every
family should definitely check it out on
disney plus the one and only ivan with
brian cranston
um angelina jolie sam uh
sam rockwell and you just to name four
yeah
yeah that's good thanks for the call
very much i'm glad you enjoyed it
big time big time right back at you
that's danny devito right here on the
rich eisen show